In the Forecast Fragment class,
we add the Callback interface
that was provided in the gist.
Then, in the onCreateView method,
we modify the list item click behavior.
When an item is clicked, instead of
always launching a new intent to
the detail activity,
we want to notify the Callback instead.
We call getActivity and
then cast it to a Callback object,
then we can call onItemSelected on it.
We pass the URI that represents
the selected location and date.
Then, in the main activity,
we implement the Callback interface.
In the onItemSelected method, we fork
the behavior based on the mTwoPane
variable that we defined earlier.
If we're in two-pane mode,
then we create a DetailFragment and
put the URI inside the arguments bundle.
Then we replace the existing
DetailFragment in
the weather_detail_container,
using the DETAILFRAGMENT_TAG.
In one pane mode, we create a new
Intent to launch the DetailActivity and
we set the data URI.
In the DetailActivity,
we modify the onCreate method to read
the data URI from the incoming intent.
We take the URI and set it as
an arguments in the new DetailFragment.
Then we dynamically add this
fragment to this container.
In the detail fragment,
we modify the onCreateView method
to read the arguments that
the fragment was initialized with.
We read the data URI and
store that in the member variable mUri.
In the OnCreateLoader method,
we remove some code that relied on
incoming intent, and
switched it to use mUri instead.
Whether this DetailFragment is in
the main activity or the DetailActivity,
it should have mUri set.
Then we're going to use mUri to
query the content provider for
the data to display in
this DetailFragment.
When you try it out on the tablet,
there is one bug related to
navigation that we should fix.
Say we select tomorrow's date, if you
navigate to the settings activity, and
then hit the up button,
the detail fragment is blank.
That's because a brand new instance
of main activity got launched, and
for a brand new instance,
nothing is selected yet.
To fix this, when the setting activity
up button is pressed, we want to
navigate to the previous running
instance of the main activity where
the tomorrow item is selected and now
create a new instance of main activity.
In the SettingsActivity, override this
method, which the system will call
in order to get the parent activity
intent for the up button behavior.
Get the parent activity
intent from the super class,
this should create a new
intent to main activity.
Then add the intent flag called
FLAG_ACTIVITY_CLEAR_TOP.
This flag indicates that we should
check if the main activity is
already running in our task.
And to use that one instead of
creating a new main activity instance.
Also this method didn't
exist prior to Jelly Bean so
we need to add this
@TargetApi annotation.
If you check the documentation for
the activity class,
the getParentActivityIntent method
was only added in API level 16,
and you can check that version
16 maps to Jelly Bean.